Speaker 1: In the meantime, we continue to
see Joe Biden's approval rating go up and
Republicans are furious. Many of them are leaving
me voicemails, which I'm not going to play because
they're just very lame. But Republicans are
now saying Biden is as unpopular as ever, when,
of course, the truth is Joe Biden has seen one
of the most rapid increases in approval rating
of any president in recent years. Now he's still
only at about 43%. And it's sort of a glass half
full, glass half empty sort of thing. You can
say, well, 43% means 15, 57% still disapprove.
But you can also look at the last several
presidencies and realize that actually 43%,
it's no incredible victory, but it's pretty
average in terms of where many presidents tend
to be during their presidencies. So taking
a look at the numbers now on the screen. You
see that Joe Biden had this sort of bottom
out at 37 and a half percent. Now, remember,
FiveThirtyEight is looking at
an average of approval polls.
So it's an it's it's based on more than one poll.
These are averages. The approval bottomed out at
37 and a half percent in the second half of July.
And it's been a basically direct increase now
to about 43%. So that's roughly an increase
of 15% in Joe Biden's approval rating. And I
have to tell you, it sort of makes sense in
that lots of good things have taken place,
many of them associated with Joe Biden. There's
this crew. It's almost quaint sounding that
a president does a bunch of stuff people like, and
then their approval rating goes up because we're
so used to this highly partizan, almost weaponized
approval rating situation where approval is
more related to propaganda rather than
accomplishments. But we now have two jobs
reports in a row that are better than expectations
under the Biden administration. We have inflation
down last month. We are days away from the
next inflation number, and my expectation
is that it's going to be down again. Significant
legislative accomplishments. Infrastructure. The
Pact Act. The Inflation Reduction Act. Student
loan forgiveness, which is very popular with
Americans. And it's reflected now in the approval
rating. And there's other things as well.
Gas prices also are continuing to experience
one of the most sustained and rapid declines
in a very, very long time. And average gas prices
peaked at $5.02 in mid-June, and it has been
declined. Decline, decline initially, very rapid,
then a little bit less rapid, but continuing down.
Gas prices are now down to 3.73 from 502a
gallon. That is a 25 ish percent, 26% decline.
That is more than a quarter chopped off of gas
prices. Everybody's gas bill down by a quarter.
This is a big, big deal. I don't even claim it has
anything to do with Joe Biden. I didn't believe
Biden was responsible for the gas prices going
up. And I don't believe Joe Biden is responsible
for the gas prices going down aside from a few
cents a gallon because of of of tapping the
Strategic Petroleum Reserve. But I'm consistent.
I don't play the gas price games with presidents,
but we know that that's something many people
do look at when answering the question, do you
approve of the job that the president is doing? So
we'll have new inflation data next week. I expect
that it will be, again, a decline in inflation.
And Joe Biden's approval rating reflecting
what is overall a pretty damn good economy by all
standard metrics. And now the question becomes,
what does it do to Democratic chances in the fall?
And the numbers continue to improve a little bit
at a time. A little bit at a time. We will delve
into those numbers in more detail tomorrow.